okay but we have
a
important guest with us one of the
greatest players of all time arguably
the greatest player of all time gary
kasparov here with us on the show hi
gary hi gary hi yes good afternoon
your first impressions of the eight
rounds of the sinkville cup gary where
have you been enjoying the action
yes absolutely okay it's uh i always say
that grunge's tour was the best proof
that classical chess
is not was not dead
so we we had you know of course you know
quite of the games were not as
as exciting as we as we wanted uh but
it's understandable because players are
tired it's a long season and obviously
you know the the pandemics had an extra
pressure on all of them
but uh so many games great games being
played yes mistakes but that's what
makes games very exciting and uh
and i think this sinful cup you know was
was
again really good demonstration
that classical chess still attracts
tremendous uh
attention of the public and and again i
was quite happy to see this so many
fighting games and great great fighting
spirit of all the players
thank you gary and alejandro gary we
have a special prize in this tournament
we have the brilliancy prize now we're
the judges we don't want you to tell us
our opinion and pollute our minds
but tell us a story about a famous
brilliancy prize you've won you must
have many through the years
you just said it you know i had many
you saw many you can't even count them
that's quite tough because you know i
i can
i'm not sure you know whether
tournaments had a special prices for
instance my game was topple off i'm not
sure there was a special prize in vegas
eh that that is a crime
yeah that's the
um actually it wasn't one brilliant
surprise you know i remember that was a
very good game
so there was not a not a clean perfect
game but no games are perfect even with
you know so if if he if he wouldn't have
taken rook on d4 and just and uh
exchanged queens he would have probably
slightly bad end game so you always need
a cooperation of your opponent but i i
would recall a game uh from
uh manila olympic yeah sir the last
round absolutely
actually the penalty round it was my
last game but i didn't play in the last
round in fact you won the uh
the brilliancy in the olympiad in manila
but the problem i think the judges had
is you had two candidates
for the brilliancy and they had to
choose which one
but this is but
nikolas was really cool
yeah it was a real really good game and
good opening so that's and and then this
is peace sacrifice so so out of blue
yeah so again it's um it's tough you
know you're testing my memory and just
again i
actually started testing my memory it's
it's it's um i would say it's the
opposite you know so pleasant because
now i'm just trying to recover
all the games
nice
of course gary this is the final
um
uh leg of the grand chess tour 2021
it was a very
difficult year for the organizers the
pandemic had so many challenges
but
it was completed it was fulfilled
uh
2022
has been announced uh there are more
tournaments uh tell us a little bit
about the new event in poland uh it's
very nice that we're expanding the uh
competitions and i
i'm very happy
that we have a new sponsor from warsaw
uh it's not just a new sponsor because
it was also be sponsored partially by
the same sponsor who is uh behind the
bucharest and and zagreb uh the super
bad company okay but there are local
sponsors and i was recently in poland i
just few days ago i had a great trip i
was in warsaw and then traveled down to
ustron it's a small town in the katowice
region and met met though this new
polish sponsor uh from company called
makate this is the largest uh
seller of tea and coffee in poland and
this is actually international business
great family business and the man who
runs it it's a big chess fan
so um he's joining now the group of
other polish sponsors and it's you know
it's some sometimes you know things work
in in a concert you know it's you say
it's a coincidence maybe it's chicken
and egg but you have a rise of chess
popularity in poland you have polish
sponsors and believe it or not what a
coincidence
young sister of duda is on the rise so
we just wonder won the world cup beating
you know magnus carlsen the world
champion and one of magnus former
challengers sergey karjaki and so in the
same and in the final of the world cup
now qualifying for candidates and again
that's that gave another boost both for
chess fans in poland and also for polish
sponsors so now duda you know definitely
will be part of of um uh branch's tour
and of course you know they get an extra
a wild card in warsaw so i'm very
optimistic so that the it's the um the
event and warsaw will not be just one
off so we're looking for you know long
term you know um uh um
um
set up in eastern europe so between
these three capitals um and again it's
it's um it's um i think great news great
news oh for our you know sponsors in
france and of course for saint louis
that now we have reliable partners in
europe that can offer us the expansion
in the region that had long-term chess
traditions i mean let's let's let's be
honest the traditions of chess in
eastern europe you know they
they they were rich and and they when
did they went down history for these 150
years so the fact is that all these
countries now are joining are joining
the grantees too
gives us a lot of confidence that our
event is going to be a dominant
chess network uh in the years to come
wonderful and i just have to ask you
i don't believe you're in the united
states and i don't believe you are in
croatia but you're in greece
yeah what are you doing in greece
uh i'm you know um it's a traditional
event that also you know i was canceled
last year because of the pandemics it's
a conference organized by stavros diaz
foundation it's a summer conference here
at nostal's conference and this year uh
it's the event is concentrating on ai
and humanity and i'm one of the speaker
sections tomorrow i'll be joining the
panel that's the last day of the
conference so um you know as you know
i'm um very active on this field as well
so and i am no i'm i'm in the room i
should i close the curtains you know
just to have sort of a better
uh um
uh
backdrop otherwise you know the knight
athens behind me
well gary that's so wonderful uh first
of all thank you for all the work you do
on the grand chess tour
much success
in
greece and uh well guys if there's
anything else you want to ask the
founder of the grand chester
now's the time what's happening what's
happening today yesterday
let's assume it i know i i don't play as
well as i used to but this probably
doesn't i do have a question
[Laughter]
i do have a question yeah gary we're
finishing up the tour here this is the
last day of play for the entire tour
wesley so won
but besides wesley what impressed you or
who impressed you from the tour
participants
um look it's again it's
it was very hectic here because as i
said it's i think the players had so
much to to to deal with and uh and again
the event was it was interrupted by by
the coveted restrictions and
it's a great period that levon aronian
couldn't take part in the last leg of
the tournament again wesley won because
he you know he proved to be the most
stable and most uh reliable player and
by the way it's not just an award in in
grand jury and look at this online
events organized by magnus chess so
wesley also did extremely well
so it's just you know it's um it shows
that you know every single day always
is
is is being you know um
paid you know for you for your hard work
and for your devotion to the game of
chess and wesley is uh
it's again that's today in in this
current environment he proved to be the
most uh resilient to all the challenges
gary if i may i don't know if you can
see my board but i definitely first of
all hello uh we i i always say we don't
get to see each other too
i can see your board you can see the
board and this is one of uh your good
buddies peter spidler who did not play
well in this event but he looks like
he's trying to win the brilliancy prize
in this round or shaping up to be in
fine style he's playing against jeffrey
zhang jeffrey played an early g5 we've
seen this happen often in this opening
but is he has he done it too early and
the queen e2 and now c6 and given peter
this incredible d4 e takes d4 bishop
takes d4 this looks like something out
of your style of play where you'll be
thinking oh boy i'm gonna have to kill
this guy
uh
look you know the position that you
showed me after move six or seven you
know is a6 and a4 and we used to see it
in in in the amateur's chest you know
they moved
their pawns age and 8 pawns but now
that's that's that's a serious chess
because you know h6 g5 is one of the new
modern plans and uh and i think again
peter responded with you know what uh
what he learned you know when it was a
kid you know so if something happens on
the on on the side so just attack in the
center so i i don't uh but uh why are
you thinking that it's just it's so bad
for black well first of all i have an
engine so that kind of helps
okay fine that's that's that's that's
but
my g6 is played plan it's a castle and
just blast it looks like a natural
weapon it just looks like and diddy
castle yeah i believe so he did knight
g6 happened castles has happened
i just i feel like i'm studying the test
of time by gary casparo
i feel like i'm studying one of gary
caspar's best games with like the game
collections where this kind of position
you see the two bishops you see the
knight the rook you just need to bring
the other pieces into play and it
doesn't feel like black is properly
poised to to deal with everything that's
coming he's played the move queen to e7
it feels just like an attacking game in
your style
okay it's the
yeah i don't want to say that the
attacking games are just my style i
guess only because there are many
players that
could you know would would probably call
this mantle as well i just you know
think that you know peter did things you
know that's quite natural so
uh though again i i don't have a luxury
look at the engine so again this is
optically doesn't
seem to be so bad for black so when i
just look at this position just look at
this position i want by the way you know
when the game is over so okay ask them
how they evaluated their position the
players
yes without having access to an engine
yeah can you show me peter's face
oh there's any chance i can look at
peter's face oh only behind a mask
gary you're not going to be able to
determine okay no no but still i'm
behind the mask but it's just uh
because what's machine recommendation
knight f1 actually not f1 that's that's
what that's that's that's what i thought
knight f1 and then gennad goes on g3
and then moved 95 so
but it's um yeah yeah i think it's just
difficult for black to to find so the
right to to to find the good um
location for for for the king yes right
yeah i can imagine that uh peter
bringing his knight to g3
gary uh
well it's very awkward for black's king
if he tries to go to the long side ace
is
hanging and he tries to go short
things could work
i still think the short might be
best choice but it's just not
doesn't look good yes i i but i i still
think you have to go short so for
example
maybe
yeah okay maybe now maybe
uh
1995
95
but the problem is now f4 is a threat
yes
exactly exactly so
bishop anything like a bishop e6
right no that's that's not that's that's
it no that's that's it oh dear there's
an execution
coming on the g file uh yeah this is
this is what uh
what the challenges that blackest is
having in uh this game uh gary i i i i
it's some good i mean
it's obviously the age you know
asia plays a role but he had some really
good games in this one
yeah
that was you know
i mean it was mvl you know that was
actually very good game it's he lost it
that banking won the terrible mistake 98
but it was you know that he had at least
two two easy ways of making a draw and
it was a very high quality game yeah
it's not been not for the brilliant
surprise but it was a good game both
played played with a lot of creativity
so that was a great game and it's
repeated that he just you know instead
of k8 he made his terrible blunder 98
and just you know and then lost
fantastically
gary i think it's a question that a lot
of people uh who follow the grand chess
store would like to ask
could you give us any insight as to
whether or not magnus carlsen might be
in the next cycle
it's magnum's decision so we are again
we we invited him this year he just
decided that he had other things to do
he'll be invited again of course no
doubt about it and it's it's for him to
decide so we
we are not you know we cannot force him
to do the things of course it's i think
it was a great pity he didn't he didn't
take part
in these uh branches tour so we'll see
what happens you know next year but
before before you know next year we'll
see what happens in dubai
yeah
so is the
so i am i'm quite confident we'll have
nepal joining us next year
so
as as one of the top players or
god knows as a new world champion so as
for magnus whether he will be the world
champion and again as you know i think
he's a favorite in the match or
you'll be newly you know
newly cooked ex-world champions so it
will be easy to make
all right gary well thank you so much
for joining us again any questions more
furthermore
gary do you choose to lose what in in
ten days yeah yeah absolutely absolutely
have a good time in greece see you soon
take care guys thank you thank you for
joining us